de 4 heures 80% de sa communauté et
partie en fumée une quinzaine de maisons
et des kilomètres de forêt la communauté
métisse d'espery et défigurée
méconnaissance
[Musique]
de l'ampleur de la tâche qu'il attend
c'est comme des sports
[Musique]
du conseil de la communauté et l'accord
donné l'évacuation des quelques 300
résidents disparus
[Musique]
l'enseignant de profession porte
maintenant plusieurs chapeaux hey
besoins primaires des évacués à combler
le Conseil doit aussi planifier la
reconstruction
[Musique]
du pont de la route principale à
reconstruire aux lignes électriques il y
a beaucoup à faire
et tout ça alors que le feu continue de
faire rage ou limite de la communauté
pompier à la retraite Kevin Neymar a
vécu la majeure partie de sa vie à
espérer il a passé les derniers jours à
combattre les flammes
avec d'autres volontaires il tente
maintenant de bâtir une zone pare-feu le
long de ce qu'il décrit comme un monstre
énorme
se dit en mode survie la scène qui
l'entoure lui apparaît surréaliste et le
pire
[Musique]
du feu qui dort et que sa communauté
n'est pas encore tout à fait hors de
danger il sème Levasseur a du Canada
dans la communauté métissée